bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
l'antenne de lcp et public sénat nous
sommes ensemble pour revoir en 45
minutes les temps forts de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec vous
mickaël szames sg cutter bonjour michael
et le débat a donc été suspendue sur la
loi elle conneries le gouvernement à
engager la responsabilité sa
responsabilité sur le texte
le projet de loi donc été adopté en
première lecture après le rejet d'une
motion de censure déposée par la droite
rendez-vous maintenant au sénat
cette séquence politique et
parlementaire risque de laisser des
traces au sein même du parti socialiste
les divisions d'éclater au grand jour
autres fondeurs et député loyalistes
tandis qu'au dehors la colère ne faiblit
pas dans les rangs des opposants à cette
loi et puis il y avait un texte moins
polémique née important les sénateurs
ont voté la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence qui s'appliquera donc au moins
pendant l'euro de football organisée en
france notre invité cette semaine pour
commenter toute cette actualité jean
marc germain bonjour bonjour député ps
des hauts-de-seine proche de martine
aubry doit pas forcément d'accord avec
ce que fait le gouvernement je vous
propose d'en parler évidemment dans un
instant vous avez vu le menu beaucoup de
choses on va commencer cette semaine par
cette actualité
un parlementaire soupçonné d'agression
sexuelle denis baupin car il s'agit de
l'ue député écologiste soupçonné
d'agressions sexuelles de harcèlement
par ses propres collègues
tout est allé très vite puisqu'il a dû
démissionner de la vice-présidence de
l'assemblée nationale les explications
de françois goulard
c'est le site internet mediapart et
france inter qui révèle le scandale
les journalistes ont recueilli les
témoignages de huit femmes dont 4 élus
écologistes qui auraient subi des actes
de harcèlement ou d'agression sexuelle
de la part de denis baupin l'une d'elles
explique avoir reçu pendant plusieurs
mois des sms très crue du député
écologiste
ça a duré plusieurs mois il y avait plus
de 150 sms de ce type là alors j'ai un
peu parlé avant et j'en ai parlé à
plusieurs personnes
mais comme on nous dit que ça nous
détruira et qu'en plus on allumera le
parti et puis que c'est un mec
formidable qui défendent nucléaire et
que les intérêts du parti doivent passer
avant le reste eh ben on se tait au sein
du parti d'europe écologie les verts que
denis baupin a quitté le mois dernier la
nouvelle direction se dit écoeuré on
ressent un sentiment de honte c'est mon
cas le fait que dans notre parti et puis
l'avoir ce type d'agissement dont j'ai
aucune raison de douter de la véracité
et puis aussi un sentiment de
reconnaissance et de fierté vis-à-vis
des femmes qui ont eu le courage de dire
les choses puisque le seul remède par
rapport à ce type d'agissement enfants
en tout cas la seule façon de les faire
reculer
c'est de le dire le président de
l'assemblée nationale de son côté n'a
pas tardé à réagir
claude bartolone a reçu monsieur denis
baupin il lui a demandé de remettre sa
démission de ses fonctions de vice
président de l'assemblée nationale
denis baupin qui n'a répondu à aucun
média pour le moment a annoncé qu'il
quittait son poste de vice-président de
l'assemblée mais conteste les
accusations de harcèlement sexuel
il envisage de porter plainte pour
diffamation alors depuis le niveau pas à
porter plainte
simplement quand vous apprenez cette
nouvelle lundi matin comment vous
réagissez
c'est quoi votre première impression moi
je suis abasourdi parce que on connaît
tous denis baupin et personne ne pouvait
imaginer ça vous le croisez dans les
colorants même la grande halle et en
même temps vous savez moi j'ai été
surpris aussi par l' affaire strauss
kahn
en son temps et est donc on sait que ces
harcèlements existent dans la société
moi aussi je salue le courage des femmes
qui l'ont dénoncé
mais je salue aussi la dignité
au fond de la façon dont cette affaire a
été gérée monsieur baupin a démissionné
de ses fonctions de l'assemblée
nationale la ville est ravie dont il n'a
pas quitté son poste d eau et deux
vice-présidents l' affaire a été portée
devant la justice
sa femme sa conjointe emmanuelle cosse
s'est exprimé aussi à la fois en
soutenant en tant que conjoint mais en
demandant que cette affaire soit réglée
devant la justice et donc je trouve
qu'au fond cette affaire a été traitée
de manière assez digne par les
responsables poliment dépasse sa
démission en tant que parlementaire non
je souhaite qu'ils puissent s'expliquer
et se défendre devant la justice et que
nous en tant que politique
d'abord que chacun en tire la leçon dire
bien sûr on a des femmes et des hommes
comme les autres et que ces affaires
elle existe dans le monde professionnel
et dans les vies privées de chacun mais
non on doit être exemplaire et ça doit
pas être toléré
encore moins peut-être dans la vie dans
la vie publique et puis après il faut
aussi penser au problème lui-même et la
question elle-même que ça soulève
moi par exemple pour moi être socialiste
cette féministe donc je souhaite que ce
genre de comportement soit bannie de
notre société vous dites ça aujourd'hui
ça a été dit par le passé au sujet
d'autres affaires est ce que vous pensez
que ça peut être un déclic ou qu'il y
aura encore une autre affaire et que
c'est un éternel recommencement
on dit les choses et puis on a
l'impression que de nouvelles affaires
se révéler que rien ne change
je pense que le fait pour ces femmes
d'avoir dit ces choses là et ensuite
faits seront établis ou pas on verra va
faire progresser effectivement le
respect de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
et c'est très important quelque chose a
changé selon vous la parole s'est
libérée sur le plan juridique je crois
pas puisque nous allons voter des lois
en début de quinquennat et qui
permettent de sanctionner le harcèlement
sexuel de manière très forte sur le plan
des comportements bien sûr il faut il
faut que ça progresse
ou c'est moi je pense que ce qui
permettra de faire vraiment évoluer les
choses c'est la parité totale à
l'assemblée nationale c'est la parité
totale dans le monde politique et moi je
plaide par exemple pour que les partis
politiques qui n'ont pas non seulement
autant de femmes et d'hommes candidate
mais autant de femmes et d'hommes élus à
quelque chose près parce qu'on mesure
pas
tu as des élections de manière très
précise et bien aiguisé plus de
subventions publiques parce que je vous
assure
quand dans les grandes entreprises vous
avez des femmes qui rentre dans les
conseils d'administration ça fait
évoluer les choses et quand dans un
conseil municipal c'est déjà le cas et
maintenant les conseils généraux vous
avez autant de femmes que d'hommes et
bien ça fait vraiment évoluer le
comportement politique
alors je vous propose de nous rendre
mardi au sénat où a été voté la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
deux mois supplémentaires le sénat a
validé la prolongation d'état d'urgence
pour la troisième fois
3 109 sénateurs ont voté l'objectif est
d'assurer la sécurité de la france
pendant l'euro de football et le tour de
france état d'urgence doit prendre fin
théoriquement le 26 juillet deux jours
après l'arrivée de la grande boucle
jean marc germain députés et sénateurs
ont rédigé un texte commun sur cette loi
qui prolonge état d'urgence il ya
consensus qui n'est pas si fréquent
surtout ces derniers temps vous voterez
aussi ce texte en séance publique
c'est à dire la semaine prochaine oui
bien sûr et je voudrais saluer le
travail que mène bernard cazeneuve qui
est très difficile parce qu'il essaie
d'assurer au fond la liberté de
manifester on en parlera peut-être dans
votre journal de d'avoir des grands
événements footballistiques y compris
qui est des fans zones où les
supporteurs pourront se retrouver et en
même temps la fermeté et la sécurité
vous savez la facilité pour lui sera été
dire il n'y a pas de manifestation il ya
pas de fan zone etc
non il prend rien et qui dit-il 38 pour
moi l'aller on a trouvé un équilibre et
booster son à trouver cet équilibre
c'est parce que derrière il ya un homme
qui porte sa en lui comment assurer la
sécurité et c'est un ministre de
l'intérieur très faire mais en même
temps comment assurer les libertés et il
est toujours à l'écouté quand il ya des
associations qui le saisissent par
exemple en disant attention porte
atteinte aux droits fondamentaux il dit
ballet pas ça d'un revers de la majorité
il essaye de corriger les livres qu'ils
incarnent la sécurité il incarne
l'articulation entre la sécurité la
liberté profondément
il ya quand même des manifestations vous
en parler à l'est
des débordements encore une fois depuis
des semaines et vous entendez par
exemple ceux à droite mais pas que qui
dit comment est ce possible alors qu'on
venait en plein état d'urgence
et c'est vrai qu'on est en droit de se
poser cette question mais parce que si
on interdisait de manifester dans notre
pays sur des questions aussi
fondamentales que les relations de
travail travail c'est ce qu'on a pour
vivre quand on le perd on perd quasiment
tous si on pouvait pas manifester on en
n'est pas d'accord pour sept lots vous
rendez compte de la victoire honda et
chig manifestations et agit des casseurs
non mais vous avez les manifestants et
vous avez les cages ils sont d'ailleurs
comme les forces de l'ordre victimes des
casseurs vous avez vu hier qu'il ya des
services d'ordre de la cgt qui s'est
fait taper dessus par des casseurs et
vous avez des casseurs d'ailleurs dont
l'effet est plus de discréditer le
mouvement que quoi que ce soit donc ils
sont là pour taper mais en même temps
est-ce que pour autant il faut interdire
je crois que les décisions que prend
bernard cazeneuve d'essayer d'encadrer
au mieux et des efforts ont été faits
des deux côtés il ya des renforcements
des forces de l'ordre il est des
renforcements des services d'ordre des
des syndicats voilà or cette semaine
vous savez ça a été marqué par ce
psychodrame autour de la gauche molle 49
3 on va y venir dans un instant
simplement je voulais vous entendre sur
les propositions venues de la droite les
propositions économiques ont lancé un
petit peu plus
cette semaine alain juppé s'est dévoilée
voici le reportage de sophie nommant
couturier fait une sorte d'état des
lieux
il est le premier à avoir lancé un pavé
dans la mare en matière de proposition
libérale c'est françois fillon qui donne
le ton des jouets en 2014
l'ex premier ministre présente alors un
projet de rupture revenant sur plusieurs
acquis sociaux 110 milliards d'euros
d'économies mais surtout la fin des 35
heures la retraite à 65 ans la
suppression de l'usf ou encore la
facilitation des licenciements
économiques
ses concurrents n'aurait pas osé mais
devant cette radicalité
il se décomplexe et lui emboîte le pas
alain juppé le favori des sondages
préconise à son tour 100 milliards
d'euros d'économies la fin des 35 heures
la retraite à 65 ans est lui aussi la
suppression de l' isf au coeur de son
projet économique la relance de la
compétitivité des entreprises par une
politique de l'offre
nicolas sarkozy et bruno le maire plaide
aussi pour un plan d'économies drastique
et proposent respectivement 100
milliards d'euros pour l'un et 90
milliards d'euros d'économies pour
l'autre la retraite à 65 ans 64 pour
nicolas sarkozy est toujours la
suppression de l isf mais aussi
l'alignement des régimes du privé du
public comme le souhaite également les
deux autres candidats ainsi que la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
et c'est sans compter la diminution du
nombre de fonctionnaires et la baisse
des prestations sociales dégressivité
des allocations chômage et création
d'une allocation sociale unique idée
partagée par les quatre favoris de la
primaire à droite alors à ceux qui
disent la fin du clivage droite gauche
vous avez la réponse est oui je crois
qu'elle est très clairement montré par
votre reportage on va parler du 49 3 mai
ou si je devais résumer dire une seule
raison pour laquelle j'ai pas voté la
motion de droite hier sexy elle avait
été votée il y aura eu dans un mois le
retour de la droite au pouvoir avec la
retraite alors ça dépend des candidats
mais 65 66 67 ans avec au moins trois
cent mille suppressions d'emplois
publics avec la suppression des 35
heures et c'est avec ses cours par
exemple la suppression d'une bien sûr
que non vous savez notre pays souffrent
d'inégalités et les iguanes égalité les
plus fortes elles sont font pas par le
mérite par la création et moi j'admire
les chefs d'entreprises qui sont
capables d'inventer des nouveaux
produits et à la limite de gagner de
l'argent autour de ça ce qui va pas
c'est que quand on est et on est certain
qu'ils aient des millions et d'autres
rien du tout donc c'est la question des
successions et c'est la question des
grandes fortunes gala juppé a présenté
son programme séduit l'ennemie de la
gauche aujourd'hui goûter jus c'est pas
très différent les candidats entre les
uns et les autres noms dont il fait lui
qu'est l'euro dans les sondages
oui on prendra le candidat que la
première de la droite choisira c'est pas
à nous de le faire mais ce qu'on voit
bien c'est que ce coup dur l'agglo tout
cas ça sert à rien la jupe et sa chambre
moi je parle pas de danger c'est la
démocratie avait compris le danger là
celui qu'elle devait fait celui qu'elle
plus de chances de l'emporter à la
primaire d'abord et ensuite face à nous
c'est clairement alain juppé c'est lui
qui a la chance de pouvoir gagner même
si c'est oui parce qu'il a su construire
un rapport à l'opinion
à faire oublier ce qu'il avait fait
quand il était premier ministre et à ce
qu'on parle pas tellement de son
programme mais vous le faites et c'est
très bien 1 vous propose de revenir au
sujet de cette semaine qui concerne au
premier chef une réunion mardi de la
dernière chance à lui à matignon
mais l'espoir de compromis s'est vite
éloignés faute de majorité pour voter la
loi travail le gouvernement a donc
décidé d'utiliser l'article 49-3 sur la
loi travail une décision dénoncée à
droite comme à gauche françois moulin le
conseil des ministres qui s'est réuni
sous la présidence du chef de l'état m'a
habilité engagé la responsabilité du
gouvernement
c'est donc le passage en force qu'a
choisi manuel valls
une décision que le premier ministre
avait déjà prises le matin même après
une réunion de la dernière chance à
matignon avec les frondeurs du ps où
aucun compromis n'est trouvé
si le 49-3 est devenu réalité disent les
députés fidèles au gouvernement
c'est à cause des opposants socialistes
je fais le constat qu'une minorité de
députés du groupe socialiste se
positionne comme s'il était majoritaire
mais en fait ils le sont par alliance
avec la droite pour des raisons qui sont
encore une fois des postures politiques
des collègues ont choisi une méthode
dure je la considère comme tel
dont acte la décision d'utiliser le 49-3
avant la fin des discussions
parlementaires est un déni de démocratie
pour les frondeurs ça va on n 10 mais le
10 mai et l'élection de françois
mitterrand en 1981
je sais un triste symbole que
aujourd'hui le gouvernement soit obligé
de recourir aux 49 3 sur un texte qui
n'a pas la majorité ni même la majorité
des députés socialistes dans l'hémicycle
les débats ont été houleux et les
députés front de gauche sont venus
renforcer les rangs des opposants à la
loi
qui aurait pu imaginer qu'un
gouvernement serait que la marque de la
gauche hausse ainsi anéantir notre
modèle social
fierté de notre pays manuel valls en a
profité pour rappeler combien ce texte
est nécessaire à ses yeux ce texte qui
est bon pour les entreprises qui est bon
pour les salariés
qui crée de nouveaux droits pour les
salariés et bien ma responsabilité et
notre responsabilité c'est d'avancer et
de faire en sorte que ce texte soit
adopté
quant à la droite elle a déposé une
motion de censure pour faire tomber le
gouvernement à rendre compte plus les
recours aux 49 3 est ce que celui ci
pour vous était prévisible est ce que
c'était la conclusion logique de tout ce
qui s'est passé d'internement et plus
aucune chance de compromis non se tenir
à profonde et il y avait une chance de
compromis moi je l' ai mis sur la table
dans la réunion que nous avons eue avec
le premier ministre n'ont d'ailleurs sur
le coup le premier ministre n'a pas dit
non il a fait lui-même une proposition
et on s'est quittés comme ça sans
conclusion puis ensuite je crois qu'il a
passé un coup de fil au président de la
république et que le quart d'heure et
des maillots langage et je sais pas mais
en tout cas c'était tardif cette réunion
elle aurait dû avoir lieu avant le dépôt
du projet de loi
ou juste après parce que vous savez la
démocratie en dehors de situations liées
à la défense nationale
c'est trouver des majorités de
construire des majorités et c'est le
rôle du premier ministre
car les entendais j'entendais le
rapporteur dix 10 ans et un certain
nombre de parlementaires qui bloque les
choses alors que la majorité du groupe
socialiste et pour d'abord il ya eu un
vote qui a eu lieu en fait il aurait eu
lieu dans la réunion des socialistes où
il y avait alors il y avait des absents
je dis pas que c'est le rapport de force
au sein du groupe g mais il y avait eu
84 voix pour donc les seules voies que
rond sûrs au bout du bout ce projet si
on en arrive pas à voter un moment donné
il reste encore la deuxième lecture ce
sera ses 84 voix
donc on voit bien que en démocratie ça
peut pas être 84 parlementaire ou même
plus je suis honnête avec vous si ça
avait été dans l'hémicycle il y aurait
peut-être eu 200 personnes 220 mais y
aurait pas eu de 190 personnes
et ça c'est pas possible moi je suis
pour la suppression de l'article 49 3
qui est une aberration de la vème
république et qui comptent qui conduit à
faire des fautes politiques parce que
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd hui même
du touât autant obama
politique sionko vous dites oui et quand
je dis ça c'est pas de l'agressivité
vis-à-vis de manuel pas c'est une
réflexion que j'ai et un débat que je
veux avoir avec lui parce que comment
elle peut avoir une légitimité cette loi
il ya plusieurs méthodes ça aurait pu
être dans notre programme devant les
électeurs en 2012 c'est pas le cas on
avait promis il inverse sera pu être un
accord entre le patronat français et la
majorité des accords des syndicats comme
ça a été le cas en 2013 moi même j'étais
rapporteur d'un texte comme ça a fini
justement il faut y avoir des clés sur
les chances de dialogue et il y aurait
pu avoir le soutien public si ce qui
n'est pas le cas donc mais vous avez
raison de dire que c'est pas fini
c'est pour ça que moi je fais la
proposition l'agonie son parcours
retrouvons nous autour de la table mais
pas deux heures avant le prochain 49 3
dès cette semaine
et moi j'ai fait des propositions parce
que si on avait été en dix ans cette loi
on n'en veut pas c'est tout ou rien le
comprendre et à la limite le premier
ministre disant moi il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui sont bonnes pour le
pays je veux les faire avancer
mais on n'est pas dans cette situation
on a fait des propositions très
concrètes
trois ou quatre amendements qui sont pas
des détails bien sûr qu'ils sont autre
chose importante
voilà qui consiste vous savez le premier
ministre il veut favoriser la
négociation d'entreprise nous ont dit ok
mais il faut l'encadrer par deux choses
le principe de first air que ces accords
doivent être plus favorable que les
accords de manche ou que les règles
de la loi et puis deuxième élément que
les branches professionnelles qui
régissent les règles dans le secteur
d'activité définissent dans quel cadre
ça ça fait longtemps que vous avez lancé
cet appel ça date pas d'hier
vous avez reçu une réponse ou pas d'un
mot et apprenant le parent a reçu de
réponse négative si ce n'est le 49-3
bien sûr ça c'est une forme de réponse à
venir qui n'a pas vraiment envie de
discuter
oui mais la porte reste ouverte et
passent du temps pour aboutir parce que
si à la nouvelle lecture qui sera la
dernière
il n'ya pas 289 plus un député cette loi
ne sera jamais la queue c'est pour vous
êtes vraiment par le passage à une
majorité socialiste pour voter ce texte
en deuxième lecture à la fois
aujourd'hui non mais mais si on va dans
le sens que nous proposons qui rejoint
d'ailleurs celui que propose un certain
nombre de députés que vous appelez
d'ailleurs frondeurs loyalistes enfin
c'est un peu bizarre de parler de ça
c'est le mot les mots qui sont dans
l'opinion publique
mais les frondeurs il se considère comme
loyalistes parce qu'ils font ce qu'on
avait promis aux électeurs et les eaux
et sont surmontés
voilà enfin repasser à la suite du
feuilleton ce mercredi la gauche
légèrement éparpillés justement alors
peut-on vraiment parler de cassure on va
voir toutes les explications avec ce
reportage signé françois chevret ce
mercredi 16h35 et pas de motion de
censure de gauche déposés sur le bureau
du président de l'assemblée nationale
vraisemblablement mesure
des causes de cette censure
- nous avons cru 50 sociale le matin les
frondeurs se réunissaient à huis clos
pour se mettre d'accord
non ils ne voteront pas la motion de la
droite déposé la veille
oui ils veulent constituer leur propre
motion il leur reste alors quelques
heures pour rassembler 58 signature
c'est dur parce que les d'élèves
permettant forcément de rassembler tout
de suite autant de personnes que l'on
voudrait plaît que le temps ne manquera
mais ce qui compte c'est leur origine
démarche politique on va essayer
rapidement le groupe des communistes et
front de gauche signe ainsi que la
gauche des écologistes à 15 heures
pendant les questions au gouvernement
les frondeurs font des pieds et des
mains pour trouver de nouveaux
signataires dans les rangs socialistes
16h15 l'écologiste noël mamère donne
l'état des avancées il nous manque très
peu de voix sa seconde de moins que les
doigts d'une main
à moins de cinq minutes de l'heure
fatidique l'espoir fait place à
l'évidence seuls 56 députés apportent
leur soutien à la motion de censure
il en manque donc de mai les signataires
refusent de parler d'échec parce que
c'est pas rien d avoir essayé de déposer
cette motion de censure on n'a pas voulu
voter la motion de censure de la droite
parce qu'on n'a pas voulu être dans une
forme d'incohérence politique sur le
fond mais on essaie de réunir des hommes
et des femmes de gauche des
parlementaires des députés je raisonne
en termes de devoir nous a semblé
nécessaire de faire ça nous a semblé que
c'était notre devoir mon mari on l'a
fait près d'une trentaine de députés
socialistes ont signé la motion une
division comme le groupe ps n'en avait
jamais connu
donc la motion de censure a été discutée
jeudi on en reparlera dans un instant
essayant d'élever un tout petit peu il
ya deux gauches irréconciliables a dit
manuel valls pour vous aussi à deux
gauches irréconciliables aujourd'hui non
pas du tout et je pense même que si on
n'arrive pas à réconcilier les deux
gauches
oui on a même
plus d'ailleurs une gauche communiste
une gauche sociale démocrate une gauche
socialiste et les écologistes aussi qui
font bien entendu partie de la liste moi
je parle de la gauche en général parce
que bon mois parti socialiste et la
gauche c'est ça n'a pas de sens de les
distinguer je dis que si on n'arrive pas
à réconcilier ces gauches
nous ne reviendrons jamais au pouvoir
moi je cherche pas le pouvoir pour le
pouvoir mais mais pour roger donc il
nous faut qu'ils nous font confiance
oui nous y sommes mais vous voyez bien
qu'on arrive même plus fin le premier
ministre n'arrive plus à gouverner avec
une majorité puisque comrie déchéance de
nationalité
non mais vous savez le premier ministre
il n'ya plus de majorité jean marc jahn
sur ce texte n'a pas une majorité c'est
une évidence une aura regardé gouverner
bien sur l'institutionnel et que la
constitution le lui permet mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que le premier
ministre ait encore une fois quand je
dis ça je pense qu'ils aient besoin de
respect dans la vie publique et c'est de
construire une autre majorité il le
revendique il a essayé de trouver des
voix au centre et y compris en écoutant
les parlementaires du centre qui a lui
ont fait des propositions mais au moment
du vote ils n'ont jamais été là il a
aussi écouté le patronat qui demandaient
des aides
il les a accordées qui demandaient les
souplesses il les a accordées et vous
voyez qu au moment d'être au rendez vous
de soutenir un texte il dépose le
patronat le lâchent des lustres il faut
écouter la gauche jeudi à manuel valls
que la tentative
on peut la partager ou pas mais elle a
échoué de recomposer la majorité
différemment donc je lui dis comme je
lui avais dit aux premiers jours de son
mandat de premier ministre de ses
fonctions de premier ministre il avait
la gentillesse de me recevoir à matignon
je lui avais dit il faut que tu sois le
patron de la gauche et de l'écologie un
premier ministre peut être que ça parce
que notre majorité
elle est issue de 2012 on peut rêver
d'autre chose pour le prochain avec un
canard mais dans ce quinquennat là il
n'y a pas d'autres majorités que celle
qu'ont voulu les français c'est la
manière dont vous y prenez pour recoller
les morceaux entre ces deux gauches
irréconciliables qu'est-ce que oui
qu'est ce que pour ça je dis rien c'est
pour ça que je veux dire un mot sur la
motion de censure parce que il ya des
gens qui m'aiment bien dans ma
circonscription et dans le pays qui
m'ont dit
monsieur le député jean-marc pourquoi
est-ce que tu n'as pas de signer cette
motion comme ça il aurait pu arriver aux
58 et serait bloqué la loi on ne saurait
pas bloquer la loi il fallait qu'ils
aient une majorité de gauche pour pour
la bloquer c'est pour ça que je n'ai pas
fait parce que cette démarche n'avait
aucune chance d'aboutir au real a fait
croire un certain nombre de personnes
qu'on avait la capacité de bloquer non
les députés n'ont pas la capacité de
bloquer cantilien 49,3 tout ça pour rien
depuis 1962 jamais aucun aucune motion
de saint jean ce que vous avez n'aboutit
donc donc si donc voilà je voulais pas
je voulais pas le faire par ailleurs les
frondeurs avaient eux mêmes la capacité
en leur sein de dépasser les 58
puisqu'on en a plusieurs qui est parmi
eux qui n'ont pas signé
et puis deuxième point c'est là où je
voulais en venir moi je ne renonce pas à
et je réponds à votre question à
réconcilier à ressouder ses de gauche et
donc je veux je ne veux pas faire des
actes inutiles sur le plan du résultat
moi je veut bloquer la loi et s'il y
avait un moyen de la bloquer je leur ai
fait mais qui par contre secret des
cicatrices profondes c'est ce que
j'appelle la dérive des continents c'est
de gauche qui s'éloigne de plus en plus
qu'un jour jusqu'au jour mais c'est pas
encore le cas où elles seront
irréconciliables et où la loi ne pourra
plus revenir aux responsabilités mais on
retient quand même un geste inutile
finalement cette motion de censure
la motion de censure de gauche et la
motion de censure de droite parce que la
question s'est posée les communistes
l'ont d'ailleurs être une opposition
elle aura abouti à quoi au retour de la
droite et donc quel aura été le premier
acte de la droite
moi je les imagine très bien il aurait
pris la loi comme ray dans sa loge sa
version 0 et ils auront dit un monsieur
valls madame elle comme ris et
parlementaire votée cette loi là et donc
on aura eu la loi elle comme ray empire
donc moi j'ai pas voulu de vendeurs
d'ailleurs pas non plus que reste-t-il
de cette loi travail jean marc germain
de quel texte parle-t-on exactement
depuis que le gouvernement avait décidé
d'utiliser le 49-3 sur ce texte vous
propose cet éclairage de rym ben ameur
voici le texte qui sera adoptée après le
49-3 c'est la version sortie de
commission des affaires sociales sauf
sur trois mesures très importantes
le gouvernement a cédé sur un point
les licenciements économiques à
l'origine il souhaitait que ce soient
les résultats en france qu'ils soient
prises en compte pour justifier les
licenciements économiques
finalement ce sera le périmètre
international comme le voulait le
rapporteur et les députés de gauche
en revanche le gouvernement ira jusqu'au
bout sur l'autre point explosif les
accords d'entreprise un accord
d'entreprise pour a primé sur un accord
de branche
il y a donc bien une inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes très décriée par
les syndicats et la gauche
chaque année les branches dresseront un
bilan de ces accords le gouvernement a
fait un geste en direction du medef sur
la surtaxation des cdd il abandonne
cette idée censé limiter les embauches
précaire en tout le gouvernement
retiendra 469 amendements sur les 5000
déposés sur le projet de loi travail
alors vous dites que la porte est encore
ouverte pour éviter un nouveau 49,31
lecture à l'assemblée
sur quoi précisément vous avez dit tout
à l'heure que le premier se pouvait
faire un geste sur quoi doit-il faire un
geste par exemple sur cet article 2 très
contesté qui inverse la hiérarchie des
normes
oui je crois que c'est le plus important
si on devait hiérarchiser je parle on
dira alors si des normes
pourquoi pourquoi c'est dangereux cet
article parce que vous allez avoir une
concurrence un dumping social qui va se
mettre en place entre les entreprises
vous donne juste un exemple imaginons
que un constructeur automobile qui
pourra le faire si cette loi est votée
au bout du bout des sites de dire les
heures sup chez nous c'est pas
25 c'est 10 et l'autre constructeur et
bat s'aligner au final vous avez quoi
deux entreprises qui se retrouvent au
même niveau et les salariés qui se
retrouvent lésés sans parler du fait que
les mêmes d'entreprises vont dire à tous
leurs sous traitants
écoutez maintenant si vous voulez rester
référencé chez nous vous devez passer à
10% aujourd'hui vous avez un accord de
la métallurgie qui a été signé entre les
représentants de la métallurgie et leur
syndicat qui a dit non nous les 25 on
n'y touche pas c'est la même chose pour
tous mais qu'est ce qui est bien ça il
faut pas que ce soit possible
ou alors il faut que ce soit possible
s'il ya des contreparties très forte
pour laisser réclamant est capable de
faire un geste sur cet article de
calculatrices casio et vous dire une
chose si je vais vous dire une chose il
ya un an jour pour jour avec le premier
ministre nous avons signé un texte et
l'ensemble de ses ministres et la
ministre du travail où nous avons écrit
noir sur blanc n'ont pas simplement nous
conserverons la hiérarchie des normes
nous rétablirons la hiérarchie des
normes
donc je ne conçois pas que ce qui a un
an nous réunissait nous sépare
aujourd'hui en revanche parce qu'il faut
bien avancer moi je peux pas dire je
veux tous mes amendements rien que mes
amendements et sinon elle n'appelle pas
ça un compromis sinon je veux pas moi ce
que j'ai dit au premier ministre que
l'on peut partager ensemble l'idée qu'il
faut développer la négociation
collective en france par rapport à la
loi mais des accords d'entreprise qui
adapte les lois générales où les règles
générales aussi agir local mais il faut
les encadrer
alors passé aujourd'hui parce qu'il y
avait cette motion de censure on va voir
un petit peu ce qui leur est
et donc la motion de censure a été
déposée par la droite et par le son elle
a été votée par les communistes résultat
des courses rim benameur pour l'adoption
246 la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adopté aucun
socialiste n'a apporté sa voix à la
motion de droite le gouvernement valls
n'est donc pas renverser qu'il n'avait
aucun doute
et s'il y avait eu des socialistes qui
est voté cette motion de censure le
résultat n'était connue et la droite n'a
pas réussi bien entendu à renverser le
gouvernement mais les débats à eux
marqueront les esprits dès le début de
la séance le discours de christian jacob
s'en prend violemment au premier
ministre vous n'avez plus de basse
politique et le peuple français a zappé
françois hollande en toute franchise le
mieux qui puisse se produire pour la
france c'est de mettre fin et vite à
votre aventure qui se terminera je vous
le prédis comme les années mitterrand et
comme les années jospin udi décide aussi
de voter la motion de la droite tout en
critiquant un pays à l'arrêt comme les
communistes qui dénoncent eux le coup de
force du gouvernement
ainsi le gouvernement ne veut pas
débattre de l'un des textes phares de
son quinquennat
l'humiliation le choc dans vos propres
parents étaient telles que nous avons
été à deux doigts à deux voix près de
pouvoir déposer une motion de censure
réunissant des députés de toutes les
formations de gauche
cet hémicycle une motion de gauche
signée mercredi par de nombreux
frondeurs manuel valls à la tribune les
mettant en garde
je prends cette tentative pour ce
qu'elle est elle est grave même si elle
a échoué mais leurs signataires sont
dans une impasse
mais je vous donne une conviction je ne
laisserai pas détruire la gauche de
gouvernement
la social démocratie française et oui le
temps de la clarification est venu
avec le rejet de la motion de censure le
projet de loi est donc considéré comme
adopté en première lecture
il poursuivra son parcours au sénat à
partir du 13 juin de questions jean marc
jahn la première c'est que les députés
socialistes n'ont pas pris part au vote
de la motion sanctions saint pauloise
ont eu l'envié d'en créer une
le parti socialiste a été notamment pris
part à sa route autorités pour examiner
le cas de ses députés
est-ce qu'ils doivent être sanctionnés
ont certainement pas toutes ses idées
fendre je rappelais cette signature j'ai
eu avec le premier ministre
c'était dans le cadre du congrès de
poitiers c'était c'était le texte qui
fondent les principes la profession de
foi des socialistes dans les trois ans
qui suivent ce qu'on a je vois mal qu'on
sanctionne des députés qu'on ait voulu
défendre jusqu'au bout c'est-à-dire la
première était selon vous je pense que
c'est une erreur et puis par ailleurs au
delà de sa référence
la politique c'est de construire des
majorités c'est de rassembler des femmes
et des hommes autour de soi en
l'occurrence se désocialise pas de
majorité qui sont qui sont très proches
c'est le rôle dans nos institutions du
premier ministre qui ne penseraient pas
de majorité appuyée par d'autres
donc en ce moment et vous passiez des
éléments de son discours ou le début
vous l'avez pas au passé mais j'aurais
pu être d'accord ou pas d'accord sur le
fond mais il disait je fais cette loi
parce qu'elle est bonne pour le pays
qu'il le pense normal mais alors après
il a passé la deuxième moitié de son
discours à prendre les députés les uns
après les autres et alors cogner dessus
ça c'est pas possible je veux dire c'est
ce qui est consubstantielle à la
fonction de premier ministre c'est de
construire des majorités
donc il ne construit pas ça des
majorités là il n'y a pas de majorité il
aurait pu d'ailleurs moi je le ferai
jamais si j'étais premier ministre
construire une autre majorité avec la
droite mais la droite ne veut pas donc
il n'y a pas de majorité sur ce texte et
il manque d'ailleurs bien plus que les
30 ou 40 députés qu'on a évoqué il
manque sans doute une centaine de
parlementaires et donc son travail pour
ça que je suis content le 49-3 avec le
49-3 conduit à des risques à prendre
des mauvaises décisions politiques je
retire le mot de photos tout à l'heure
si vous l'avez perçu comme désobligeants
vis-à-vis du premier ministre qui sont
pas bons moi j'ai vécu la période lionel
jospin au premier jour de son
quinquennat il a dit je n'utiliserai
jamais l'article 49-3 conséquence de ça
il passait son temps et ses ministres
aussi un discuter avec les
parlementaires
alors les français peuvent se dire les
parlementaires cdh et cher entre
guillemets qui bloque tout mais c'est
pas du tout ça la réalité
regardez sur la loi comme rri même les
frondeurs
même les communistes ils proposent pas
tout supprimer il ya des propositions
qui sont faites alors moi je récuse
l'idée part que dans le syndicalisme qui
est un peu le pendant il y aurait des
conservateurs et des réformistes
chacun veut faire avancer les choses
mais une conception différente du
programme alors va évoquer une autre
personnalité de la semaine puisque
pendant sept ans emmanuel macron avance
il prend des points dans les sondages
même s'il dément vouloir se présenter
éventuellement à la présidentielle mais
on ne parle que de lui sandra sarkar des
levées de fonds pour financer une
campagne présidentielle une candidature
en juin
emmanuel macron dément tout mais selon
son entourage rien et à exclure tout
dépendra du contexte
au mois de septembre on verra en
fonction de la décision du chef de
l'état
demain si une opportunité ou pas elle
n'est pas à exclure vous avez compris
aujourd'hui que emmanuel macron dit
lui-même qui sera loyal à l'égard de la
france bien entendu à l'égard de le chef
de l'état aussi mais loyal jusqu'à quand
car ses proches ne le cache pas emmanuel
macron rêve de devenir président et ils
y travaillent
un mouvement politique en marche bien
structuré et des soutiens de plus en
plus nombreux sa liberté c'est
formidable et il ouvre il ouvre la
perspective à ce qui est en jeu c'est
quand même la campagne présidentielle
c'est que de quel côté elle va tomber
elle va tomber côté vieux xxème siècle
ou côté jeunes 21e siècle il y a ceux
qui évoquent un pacte avec un ralliement
possible à françois hollande lors du
second tour
seul scénario possible pour les proches
du chef de l'état tout le monde à la
place dans l'équipe à partir du moment
où tout le monde est derrière le chef
d'equipe j'imagine qu'ils emmanuel
macron en tout cas je veux le croire
françois hollande miserait donc sur son
protégé pour récupérer des voix
le moment venu une stratégie électorale
à double tranchant est-ce que la
position actuelle des manuels macro qui
est milice mais qui parle même temps
ailleurs hors de nos frontières chercher
quelques soutiens est tenable pour vous
s'expliquer sur ces faits là il a été
interpellé par un parlementaire de
droite à ce sujet mais moi ce que je
voulais dire c'est que pour moi
politique ça rime avec éthique et quand
on est ministre on doit être à 100% à sa
tâche si on veut être candidat et
personne ne peut lui dénier la
légitimité à présenter sa candidature
il faut en tirer les conséquences et
partir pour qui un autre ministre qui
puisse être à 100% à redresser
l'économie chômage voilà donc soit il
met en sommeil sur sa formation
politique et s'est levée de fonds il
revient à 100% à bercy ne soit ils en
tirent les conséquences mais encore une
fois c'est une décision personnelle
moi je suis jamais à demander la
démission d'un ministre mais est ce que
vous pourriez repart dans votre voix les
mots de martine aubry
macron commandes hier album écoutez
quand elle s'est exprimée à ce sujet la
halle s'exprimer sur des sujets bien
précis ça concernait le travail ça
concerne l économie et ça visait les
politiques qu'ils qu'il même là on est
sur autre chose là on est sur la
question est ce qu'on peut préparer une
candidature à la présidentielle et être
en même temps ministre
ma réponse est non donc il faut qu'il
choisisse et empêche pas qu il pourrait
selon vous avoir la carrure d'un
président je ne suis pas du tout
prononcer là dessus je dis juste qu'il
peut être mais là qu'ils avouent la
pause
voilà un mois non j'ai pas ces jeux vous
savez pour moi la modernité en politique
c'est elle n'est pas représentée par
emmanuel macron alors si vous me disiez
qui je serai très gêné par le faire mais
je vais vous le dire quand même mais
français savent que je suppose d'elle
mais c'est plutôt anne hidalgo et ce
qu'elle fait la mairie de paris et son
éthique aussi parce qu'elle elle dit moi
je suis maire de paris les parisiens -
élu pour être maire de paris et donc je
serai pas candidate à la présidentielle
de 2017 et la prochaine c'est la
modernité en pays et elles travaillent
avec le
nouveau maire de londres et elle va
travailler avec les maires des plus
grandes villes pour essayer de faire
avancer nos idées pour essayer de faire
ma vie algo écouter ça c'est pas son
porte parole mais je voulais jurés je
voulais juste éclairé à travers sable
pour moi ce qu'est la vraie modernité en
politique on va passer à la loupe du
scan
aujourd'hui mme bonjour jean marc
germain on vient parler de d'emmanuelle
emmanuel macron justement regardez cette
scène qui s'est déroulée mardi c'était
pendant les questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée le premier ministre a été
obligé de démentir que sont mises
l'économie a cherché à lever des fonds
on vient d'en parler en vue d'une
éventuelle candidature
son excuse suivi une explication
vraiment houleuse sur les bancs des
ministres entre les deux hommes
concrètement est ce qu'ils peuvent
encore coexister manuel valls emmanuel
macron on semble d'une même équipe
gouvernementale est ce que c'est
possible
en tout cas si j'ai bien compris la
teneur de la conversation je crois que
le premier ministre ait raison de
recadrer son ministre en lui disant tu
dois être à ta tâche tu dois être au
travail et si tu veut autre chose dit le
donc moi je soutiens totalement le
premier ministre et est dans son rôle
à ce moment là après est-ce que ça peut
dire ou pas mais c'est emmanuel macron
de le dire en fonction d'eux
du débat convient d'avoir sur est ce que
il est vraiment candidat est ce qu'il a
besoin de temps pour construire et pour
préparer sa candidature et si c'est le
cas ils en ont tiré les conséquences par
rapport à son tour manuel valls a eu
raison d'eux bien sûr encore une fois
mais il est tout à fait dans son rôle
vraiment c'est l'autorité c'est
important aussi
à condition qu'elle soit utilisée à bon
escient donc l'autorité par rapport à un
ministre en lui demandant d'être apte sa
tâche c'est à bon escient par exemple 49
3 parlons maintenant un peu de françois
hollande
après paris et au la gauche vous savez
c'est ce fameux rassemblement des
ministres en soutien au bilan de
françois hollande
il devait organiser une réunion mardi
prochain à linky et la ville de martine
aubry finalement on a appris que c'était
fade le foll a annoncé que le le
rassemblement n'avait pas avoir lieu
est-ce qu'il faut il voir une
contrepartie au fait que les aubry ce
n'est n'est pas voter la motion de
censure de la gauche contre le
gouvernement écoutez pas avoir de
contrepartie parce que c'est pas un
cadeau ne pas avoir voté c'est
simplement nous vous savez on réfléchit
par rapport à notre éthique qui vous ai
dit si j'avais pensé que ça avait pu
arrêter cette loge je leur ai voté je
pense que martin brahim aurait approuvé
en ce sens en revanche je trouve que
c'est une bonne décision
d'abord cette affaire et au la gauche
franchement c'est pas compris par les
français ce n'est pas au ministre ce
port ministres d'être sur des tribunes
stéphane le foll c'est un peu différent
il anime un courant politique des amis
de françois hollande il peut le faire
mais qu'on ait des brochette de
ministres
à ce moment là vous avez les français
ils n'attendent qu'une chose en ce
moment de nous ministres ou
parlementaires c'est qu'on soit à la
tâche pour essayer de répondre aux
problèmes du pays pour essayer d'être
fidèle autant que possible on à l'europe
s'éloigne un peu de nos engagements et
je trouve que c'est vraiment pas le
moment
surtout que ça inverse un peu les choses
c'est plutôt la gauche qui dit hey ho le
gouvernement et donc et au les
parlementaires aussi vous vu qu'on n'est
pas tous d'accord
je crois qu'il faut prendre ça comme une
interpellation à notre égard active elle
a un objectif c'est crédibiliser la
candidature de françois hollande en 2017
est ce que vous pensez que cette
candidature est légitime
je dirai la même chose que pour emmanuel
macron peut-être encore plus s'agissant
d'un président sortant
parfaitement légitime a présenté
laquelle sa candidature mme en revanche
ce que je souhaite moi c'est que notre
candidat puisque vous voyez il ya des
noms qui circulent on a parlé
aujourd'hui en a d'autres qui vont
peut-être s'exprimer au mont beuvray
par exemple moi j'ai mes propres
références mais je vous en parlerai pas
d'en parler pour toi pourquoi je vous
dis ça c'est que y'a qu'une comme je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure il n'y a
qu'une seule méthode pour trancher des
désaccords politiques au sens noble du
terme
on a des différences de vue sur la loi
les conneries il ya que le vote qu'ils
peuvent être tranchées ça en démocrate
imprimeurs et bien sûr notre candidat il
ya que le vote qui permettra de dire
quel est le meilleur candidat que c'est
françois hollande et manuel marrero
arnaud montebourg benoît hamon et puis
vous savez s'il ya des primaires il y en
aura autant qu'à droite un des candidats
parce que d'aider des gens de valeur il
y en a qui sont pas très connu mais il y
en a autant que à droite donc la
primaire dit à l'adulte on m'enlève
cette prime un la primaire de la
primaire si possible avec les verts et
les communistes
3 si les verts les communistes disent
non la primaire comme en 2011 c'est à
dire avec une pluralité des candidatures
et un accès relativement facile à la
candidature avec des débats qui auront
lieu et avec un choix qui est fait par
toutes les femmes et les hommes
d'aguirre novembre vous venez parler de
deux d'arnaud montebourg et du mont
beuvray un effet il y sera lundi 7 sa
traditionnelle ascension son rendez vous
politique qui pourrait annoncer ses
ambitions en vue de 2017
l'épisode de cette semaine sur 49 3
c'est une formidable rampe de lancement
pour lui finalement est ce qui peut
profiter cet épisode je sais pas mais
moi je vais vous dire la question des
candidatures à la fronde
christian paul par exemple oui ils ont
des preuves limitées avec arnaud
montebourg mais moi je vais vous dire la
question des candidatures à ce stade
elle ne m'intéresse pas du tout parce
que je pense qu'on a à faire autre chose
c'est ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure
rck août c'est gauche se mettre autour
d'une table pour voir si on est capable
d'avoir un projet ensemble pour la
france et quand je parle des gauches
parler gauche politique
les communistes les écologistes les
socialistes et différentes tendances du
socialisme mais je parle aussi des
gauche citoyenne et des la gauche
politique parce que vous savez ces
mouvements type nuit debout ou à
l'initiative contre la loi travail et la
vigilance à l'égard des parlementaires
qu'à monter caroline de haas est ce
qu'on monte caroline de haas et sophie
binet c'est d
élément très important de la politique d
élévation que ces fictions de martine
aubry pour les prochains mois voilà et
donc on a en a expliqué hier qu'on
allait cet été proposé aux uns et aux
autres de se retrouver dans ce qu'on
appelle un carrefour de la gaude des
gauchers venez de l'écologie comment ça
va se passer
non on peut pas en dire plus à ce stade
parce qu'on en parlera quand ce sera
fait mais en tout cas notre volonté
c'est de contribuer à cette
reconstruction future des gauches
merci d'en bas et à très bientôt sa
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires